[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
president trump is back in that building
the white house recovering from the
coronavirus
but there are still so many questions
about his health and the message that
he's now sending to the country
the president as you saw removed his
mask after his return for a photo op on
the white house balcony
he went into the white house and came
back out and took off the mask and
before leaving walter reed he tweeted
this
don't be afraid of covet don't let it
dominate your life
cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent that's john
dickerson
joins us to discuss john it's always
good to see you but really
really excited to see you today i think
you can add a lot to this conversation
because i'm thinking the
200 000 plus people who have died from
this and they're grieving families
may beg to differ with the position that
the president is taking
so what message is he sending to the
public today
well the message first to look at his
return to the white house the message
he's trying to
send is that he is strong that he's
defiant that he has beaten this thing
um and some people might take it that
way but 70
or more of the country according to an
abc poll say
that the president contributed to his
own condition that he didn't take the
coronavirus
seriously and they are likely to see
this as
a problem of his own making because he
downplayed the threat he didn't wear a
mask he didn't follow the basic rules of
his own administration
and so if he uh is responsible for his
own condition
then he can hardly be triumphant in
return from something he created you
don't
get points for standing if you shot
yourself in the foot yeah and you know
what the latest poll two-thirds that's a
good analogy two-thirds of
of americans think that he's acting
irresponsibly with his messaging
do you think the white house will
reconsider their strategy here or no
no way well i don't think there's any
reconsidering because the strategy is
coming from the patient uh
so i think that um the question of
whether the president
behaved responsibly if you look at the
three main criticisms
of the administration and the
president's response to kovid
as a national crisis it's been basically
that the president has downplayed the
threat
that he hasn't put force behind the
mitigation efforts and the protection
efforts
and then that he has misled the country
with respect to how bad things are
those are the global criticisms of the
administration
those exact criticisms are being echoed
precisely
in the handling of the president's own
case and so
since the majority of the country thinks
the president mishandled the
global situation the mishandling of his
own case
that people think that he's engaged in
only echoes the larger
problem for him a problem that the whole
nation is still going through
there's a danger in this strategy of
declaring victory too isn't there john
in that if he has a relapse in the next
week or so which doctors say is
is can be a real possibility with the
coronavirus
that he might have to go back to the
hospital
that's right so that's a personal danger
for the president uh
it's also when he says don't fear covid
and and makes it look as though he's
defeated it
uh one it tramples on the feeling of
more than 207 000
families in america who've lost loved
ones
secondly it exacerbates one of the
things we know is at the heart of this
story which is that if you have money
means and power
you can get treated or maybe you won't
get covered in the first place but
you're going to be better off
than anybody in america who doesn't have
the money means and power so it
exacerbates
that issue and this is still an ongoing
story
and the the president is basically
saying everybody get back into the game
you know don't worry about this well
people are making their own risk
assessments about how they can
can inch back into normal life they're
not going to be cajoled into that we've
seen that over the months of this virus
so they may very well look at the
president and instead of hearing his
message of get back into the game they
may think
wow if the white house could become a
super spreader location
the most protected place in america
maybe this virus is
even more virulent than i thought and i
should be even more cautious
john you mentioned money means in power
many of the president's supporters don't
have money means and power
and yet they support him because he
fights on their behalf in their view
when he goes back on the campaign trail
i have no crystal ball but i'm guessing
he's going to go as soon as possible and
maybe even against expert advice
when he goes back on the campaign trail
and he meets with those supporters
how is his message his posture going to
resonate with them
well i think we saw from the supporters
who went to walter reed and who he felt
such a connection with
that he endangered the health of his
secret service by
going on that ride to wave to them the
connection between the president and his
supporters is quite strong we've known
that forever the question though larger
question is whether if he goes back out
on the campaign trail
it it surfaces all these questions that
are at the heart of this which is
whether
he is doing things for his own personal
political benefit
his own standing that are not in the
public interest
that's been a question throughout his
administration it's a question here with
respect to his personal health
and when he goes out there if he's not
following the health guidelines of his
own administration
that it reanimates all of these
questions that are at the heart of his
own personal sickness and by the way
there are 30 plus other people who were
infected at this super spreader event
i haven't seen any statement certainly
from the president or anybody else
expressing sympathy or or care for those
people who are going through a version
of what he went through
public campaign events raise all of
those questions again
and keep this center stage which is an
issue he doesn't want at the center of
his re-election campaign yeah and as we
pointed out john no evidence of contact
tracing
by the white house yet at all thank you
john dickerson we appreciate it